so we're over here on Canal Street in
New Orleans I'm looking for this joint
called Felix's boy stur bar I heard they
have some of the best hard-boiled
oysters I've never had charbroiled
oysters but I heard it's just buttery
and covered with parmesan and I'm not
used to eating it cook I like eating it
raw but seems delicious let's give it a
go I believe in this little hole area
right here is where the pop and
restaurants are now if you kind of go
ahead and read a lot of reviews people
always tell you to come to the street it
reminds me of like a little like a
little small area in Tokyo actually or
in Japan just kind of interesting that
you sit in New Orleans so this place is
just known for the oysters i'ma start
off with that first when I usually go to
a restaurant I like to try the things
that they're really known for and their
target or losers is number one is a new
early specialty and on top of that this
is what they're good at so we're gonna
give that a taste first and if that goes
well then we're order something else on
the side so I'm hungry I'm ready to grub
I love oysters a lot of people get
thrown off by wishing because of the
texture but personally I don't mind the
texture so much but I love that ocean
like seafood briny flavor that you get
from it so let's see what's happening
now everybody had a different taste
preference but when it comes to their
teeth like I said people out of New
Orleans in the south they love sweet
teeth really sweet but I'm Asian I like
my ship mild
[Music]
I don't think you guys realize how much
I love oysters number one because I am
Asian you know I have to take a picture
of this now you could have this whatever
the way you like go ahead add Tabasco
your Louisiana Hot Sauce but for me I'm
gonna just start it off very simple
right here this is what everybody has
been talking about my mouth is watering
I'm literally about to just dive into
this
that's butter and Parmesan with some
parsley on top it's 11 what else did you
say
delicious people say seafood and cheese
down low well together
[ __ ] you yes it does I'll do whatever I
like and they take this delicious herb
butter and they put it on this roll for
this bread this is it this is it for me
this is happiness on a plate this is the
Oysters Rockefeller that was recommended
we want to do that same treatment here
and there's nothing wrong with that
honestly I prefer the just irregular
travel oysters is a lot more simple the
oyster rockefeller has had a little bit
of heat to it which is perfectly fine
but it's not the heat that I like this
is it right here so I'm pretty sure you
can get this or you could do this at
home you know you can get a firewood
grill get some protects light it up
charcoal grill it yourself but you're
not going to get moister this fresh I
think food is also a part of it it's
just the experience you know we're out
here in Louisiana it makes the food
taste that much better but I don't know
too many places that use in California
so super happy that I'm here I asked the
waiter what else we should get here and
definitely while we're here I mean we're
gonna pull boy somewhere else where they
kind of specialize in it but we're here
right now so when in Rome I decided to
go and get the Felix special which is
going to be half fried oysters half
fried shrimp po-boy so a po-boy is a
classic New Orleans sandwich I'm not
gonna leave it without trying it and it
looks delicious so I can't wait how
about the bite into it we're going to
start with I believe this is the shrimp
pickles tomatoes lettuce spread
what's good you had a po-boy before
the breads a little bit different
there's a lot of strength to it meaning
that when you bite into it it's very
chewy but I think it holds up to all the
ingredients that's inside so you have
together with this type of bread
absolutely delicious fried oysters
oh yeah I mean there might be better
pull boys out there I don't know but
this isn't considered a good po-boy
I can't wait to see what else I believe
if you guys don't know the man behind
the cameras is dude Edie Edie can't eat
seafood and he tried he tried he had a
little bit of the oyster and he almost
threw up so I'm very proud of him but
they were so good
I literally demolished all 12 of those
by myself and I had half a po-boy with
deep fried oysters I haven't tried many
other restaurants yet but of course this
is not where the food exploration ends
next up we're gonna be going to the
gumbo shop so I definitely have to eat
there because I want to figure out how
to improve my gumbo that you guys see me
make before I'm super excited I cannot
wait and test me when I go there I'm
obliterate that place
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude I cannot handle heat very well at
all all I know is that when I eat this
is gonna come straight out my [ __ ]
pick up pepper spicy mango sauce hot
mango or the world's favorite smoking
[ __ ] I think I'm going to try the
smoke and [ __ ] okay cool as this one
looks like it came out the [ __ ] of a
volcano
[Music]
hmm my [ __ ] nose is what I do with
the central ass music and this [ __ ]
demon s sauce something that I really
like about towns like this I love the
architecture in the area and what I mean
by I appreciate the architecture is I
used to watch these series of
documentary films called girls gone wild
and they used to show the titties up
there
[Music]
we over here at the gumbo shop and the
reason why I wanted to come here is
because this is what they specialize it
now you can probably get gumbo in a lot
of different places but they kind of had
three things that I really wanted to try
specifically jambalaya the gumbo and
also the a2 thing there's a foundation a
lot of like Cajun and Creole cooking and
that's going to be the rule in a roux is
a mixture of half flour half fat and in
a gumbo you'll see that it's very dark
it's not it's not burnt it's just cooked
down to the point where it has like a
really deep deep flavor and with that
road you're going to extend your Trinity
of vegetable which is going to be
peppers onions and celery and from then
on you build it out it could be whatever
fish sauce beef stock whatever whatever
you have it people might be a little bit
turned off by the presentation they're
kind of like it's sloppy it's slapped on
to a plate but this wood is rustic it
has history and we're just going to get
right into this this right here my
friends is a crawfish etouffee we have
the jambalaya right here and then we
have shrimp creole I actually don't know
what shrimp creole is I'm not gonna
pretend like I do like some youtubers
out there but uh what's up guys I'm
gonna start with the the small serving
of the seafood gumbo that's what I've
been wanting to try I want to see what I
can do to my gumbo to make it better and
what better way than it tasted to
yourself
oh yeah you know what the biggest
difference between this Gumbel and my
humble is it's really seafoody and also
to my people what I'm finding out is
that when I make my gumbo I'm adding a
lot more spice than I should because
gumbo I think shouldn't be spicy but
once again you kind of manage things I
can make it just to your own palate but
definitely the rules a lot darker than
the one that I do and on top of that the
broth in the stock way better than mine
next up we have the crawfish etouffee
oh no what's great about cajun food is
that a lot of the flavors are really
deep and rich you're not going to find
cajun food that's lightly seasoned or
the flavoring isn't if not is not not
going to be present that makes sense
everything is very much in your face and
you could kind of taste like that homey
soul food type of feeling that you get
when you eat this type of food that that
is absolutely amazing we're gonna go
next to the shrimp creole looks
tomato-based tender shrimp
it's definitely tomato based it honestly
does taste like the a cheese babe
but obviously the biggest difference is
going to be that tomato and jambalaya
who is that big piece of chicken
when you a jambalaya I don't want
anybody named you guys out there to
expect it to for the rice to really kind
of gain firm and strong a lot of the
jambalaya I've had like the rice tends
to be a little bit on the mushy side I'm
not sure if that's how it's supposed to
be but that's how I've had it maybe it's
because of the way that it's cooked and
I was student a lot of broth flavor-wise
it's on point I'm not a big fan of like
militia rice but I've had jambalaya like
that which is probably one of the big
arenas Lydell making myself and I don't
like that texture in rice my flavor on
point I just did like the biggest Asian
party foul
and basically you all know that if
you're an Asian American and you take
food porn pictures you're supposed to
take a picture of the food before you
eat it but me my fat ass can't wait
sorry dug into it so a little bit of a
trick you have to take it from the side
you don't touch and thus the picture
looks like this if any of you are
running out there how like any two meals
back to back number one the food is that
delicious and number two I was shooting
on sent with Taryn earlier I knew that I
was going to eat some amazing food so I
made sure that I started myself just a
little bit more because you guys could
tell it when you guys eat food and you
eat food again even right after so even
if I was starving a little bit I just
waited it out for that one of my first
flight to be that delicious worth it I
kind of wanted to stop somewhere else to
go eat but I think I'll have to tap out
because I'm definitely at that meat I'm
full to the brim I get a little bit
overly excited about food and I know
that I shouldn't eat past a certain
point but how often do I come out to New
Orleans knowledge
I had to do it I might even get some
beignets later
[Music]